in the opening scene we are introduced
to the protagonist Bobby Reynolds who is
seen attending a job interview as usual
he is rejected by the employer due to
his criminal background it turns out
Bobby has served prison time for
manslaughter and is currently on
probation after being released from
Rikers as a result of this he is deemed
an outcast and his former friends as
well as his neighbors do not want to
talk to him Bobby has now moved to an
old apartment in East Village New York
where his lonely mother lived and died
while he was incarcerated upon arrival
Bobby takes an elevator to reach his
room numbered 519 on the fifth floor
during his Passage through the corridor
he notices a young girl playing the
piano outside room 517 as he enters his
room Bobby finds several photographs of
his late mother as well as a pillow
bearing blood stains this makes him very
sad after some time of mourning he
starts cleaning up the place in the
midst of this he overhears an argument
between a couple probably the parents of
the young girl in the adjacent room in
an attempt to Eaves drop Bobby walks out
of his room but he can't hear well he
then continues with the cleaning and
comes across a cracked hole in the wall
behind a piano curious he tries putting
his hand inside strange choice but
something Pricks his finger causing him
to bleed he quickly enters the bathroom
to wash up his wound and finds some
anti-depression tablets likely belonging
to his mother not long after he notices
an unidentified person in the opposite
apartment Window keeping a watch over
over his room however Bobby doesn't
react much to this and simply shuts the
curtain later that evening Bobby visits
a bar to meet his former girlfriend
Alysa who works there as a waitress he
asks if they can grab a coffee someday
but she refuses claiming that she works
double shifts plus she doesn't date mans
slaughterers Bobby then returns back to
his apartment with a sad expression on
his face at midnight he wakes up to a
strange sound emanating from the living
room as he proceeds to check its source
he is startled to witness his mother's
Soul pleading for help but before he can
check further she snaps out revealing
this to just be a dream the following
day he goes to the Houston auto repair
shop in hopes of getting a job this time
a supportive owner Hector Rodriguez
hires him giving him a chance to rebuild
his life but he demands his loyalty and
even offers to pay lower wages in the
beginning when Bobby agrees the owner
permits him to join the work from the
very next day later on Bobby returns to
his apartment and while on the elevator
he is is joined by a police officer
Walter it turns out that Walter is the
father of the same little girl from room
517 who often abuses his family maybe
Bobby will put his skills to work and
manslaughter him that night Bobby once
again hears peculiar scraping sounds
coming from the floor while
investigating he suddenly hears a piano
tone and discovers blood on its Keys
upon further inspection he discovers
some bloody fingernails wrapped in a
cloth inside at the piano Bobby then
consults the apartment manager showing
him the nails and inquiring if someone
else had previously stayed there before
him however the manager denies any prior
occupants and suggests that the nails
might belong to Bobby's mother he also
reveals that his mother had locked
herself in her apartment for a week
prior to her death from the next day
onwards Bobby begins working at Hector's
garage however the strange visions and
sounds continue to haunt him even during
working hours one day after work he goes
to meet Alyssa with a coffee while
walking down the street Bobby asks if
she can give him a second chance and
also invites her to visit his apartment
it's really cool my mom died in it I
keep finding blood Alysa doesn't give an
answer but she appears to be happy
returning home Bobby finds one of his
neighbors Joseph trying to listen to
something inside his room when Bobby
confronts him he reveals that he hears
strange sounds emanating from this room
Joseph asks if he hears them too but
Bobby walks inside without any response
later on he is washing the dishes when
he again then he's the argument between
Walter and his wife Gina he then walks
to room 517 door and tries to Eaves drop
on their conversation but inadvertently
makes a noise alerting Walter as a
result Bobby rushes back to his room and
shuts the door from inside just before
the cop finds him afterwards Bobby is
trying to fall asleep on the sofa when
he hears another sound from his mother's
closet he proceeds to check and finds
the place in a complete mess shortly
after he discovers a cassette that
contains some Screaming sounds of his
mother before her death this leaves him
deeply unsettled maybe she was just
recording vocals for her upcoming metal
Banger in the morning Bobby heads down
to the apartment basement for laundry on
the way he feels a strong presence of
someone tailing him the washing machine
also activates on its own without
inserting any coin leaving him puzzled
meanwhile Alyssa arrives at the
apartment and walks straight towards
Bobby's room finding the door open she
enters it and Witnesses the same
unidentified individual watching from
the opposite apartment just then a
creepy hand appears behind Alyssa's
shoulder but it inexplicably vanishes as
soon as Bobby walks in the two then have
some conversation over dinner during
which Bobby shares about how his mother
died they chat for hours and Alyssa
finally departs but not before giving
him a kiss all this creepy stuff is
Thoroughly turning her on in the next
scene Bobby again hears another argument
from room 517 this time he decides to
intervene so he bangs on the door and
asks Gina if she is okay he also offers
to help if necessary however Walter
comes out and warns him to mind his own
dang old business the next day Alyssa
comes to visit his boyfriend at his
apartments and sees Gina tapping at his
door misinterpreting the situation she
angrily leaves the place later that
evening Bobby is again disturbed by the
sound of violence next door determined
to take action he walks out of his room
only to find Carly standing in front of
his door he invites her in and asks
about the problem but the frightened
little girl remains silent she is
clearly abused by her Father which is
evident by the bruises on her body as a
last option Bobby calls the police on
Walter reporting about the physical
violence while he is on the call Carly
runs back to her room for some reason a
short while later the police arrive at
the scene and break into room 517 in an
unexpected turn of events the room is
revealed to be empty as if nobody has
lived there for several years the
officers deduced that Bobby has some
mental issues so they give him a warning
before leaving after this a perplexed
Bobby goes to the apartment manager and
inquires about the tenant of room 517
surprisingly the latter also says that
no one lives in that room now Bobby
begins to doubt his sanity in addition
he continues to hear and hallucinate
things that are not there Alyssa is
going to love this elsewhere Alyssa is
at her College talking to her friend
about Bobby here she admits that he went
to jail because of her turns out the
pair had attended a party where a
stranger approached her and began to
assault her upon witnessing it Bobby
punched him repeatedly in the face
ultimately resulting in manslaughter one
day while working in the garage Bobby is
startled when he experiences some blood
dropping on his face he frantically
rushes to the bathroom but by this time
the blood has mysteriously disappeared
Hector notices his unusual reaction and
suggests that he take a day off
meanwhile in the apartment Joseph is
seen preparing dinner but his attention
seems to be somewhere else shortly after
he goes to take out some trash when a
hand emerges from the bin and grabs him
frightened Joseph runs back to his room
and locks the door at the same time he
hears a knock on the door and upon
peeping through the hole he Witnesses a
ghostly figure of a woman asking him to
open the door in a state of panic Joseph
locks himself inside the bathroom
however he's still not safe as the ghost
walks inside with this face to face
encounter Joseph becomes so scared that
he succumbs to his fear did he die or
did he mely nearly poop himself the
following morning a detective shows up
at Bobby's place and asks some questions
about Joseph Bobby due to his criminal
history becomes the prime suspect in
this death case later at work he learns
that a car has been stolen from their
garage hack there has his suspicions
about Bobby so he asks him to return the
car within an hour or else he'll call
the police our hero is greatly
disappointed by this accusation so he
leaves saying he's innocent as the time
passes by the ghosts of Gina and Carly
continue haunting other individuals who
have connections with Bobby and the
apartment building in one instance Alysa
is at her designing class when she sees
Carly's ghost in one of her mannequins
terrified she rushes to the bathroom but
the ghost haunts her there as well on
the other hand Hector finds out that the
car was mistakenly towed Away by the
authorities this makes him regret his
earlier actions so he decides to go to
Bobby's apartment to apologize as he
gets in the elevator he finds Carly
playing with the elevator buttons he
tries to talk to her but she runs runs
away Hector follows the little girl to
room 517 where he's greeted by a grim
sight the lifeless body of Carly
panicked he proceeds to call 911 but at
the same time the little girl slowly
gets up the sight scares his heart out
prompting him to run for his life but he
doesn't get far as he falls off the
stairs leading to his tragic demise
that's what happens when you accuse My
Boy Bobby a short while later Bobby
arrives home and experiences several
visions of Carly walking inside his room
and playing on his bed disturbed by
these apparitions Bobby walks out to
interrogate other tenants about the same
one of the elderly men then reveals a
dark history years ago Walter discovered
his wife along with their daughter
attempting to leave him this enraged him
so much that he violently assaulted them
poor Gina banged each and every door of
the tenants for help but no one was
willing to intervene including Bobby's
mother as a result Walter beat his wife
to death and dumped his daughter's body
down the garbage shoot before gunning
down himself since then the ghosts of
the family have been haunting the
apartment and killing everyone who
refused to help them in need meanwhile a
frightened Alyssa arrives at the
apartment looking for Bobby but doesn't
find him in his room she then knocks on
room 517 to inquire about his
whereabouts but finds the door open as
she enters she comes across the ghost of
Walter who starts attacking her brutally
just like he did to his wife shortly
after Bobby returns to his room and
hears alysa's scaming voice he breaks
into room 517 and discovers her in a
severely wounded State worried he rushes
her back to his room and tense to her
wounds amidst this Bobby hears the
violent confrontation between Walter and
Gina again he walks out and Witnesses
the scene transpiring exactly how the
old man described it but this time Bobby
doesn't let the entire scene play out he
intervenes just as Walter is about to
deliver the final blow to Gina this
distraction allows her to snatch
Walter's night stick and beat him up
until he dies eyes in the aftermath Gina
looks back at Bobby with appreciation
after which the spirits of the mother
and daughter find peace and finally
disappear and I thought billy clubs were
Silly before with the ghosts now gone
Bobby goes back to Alysa and calls for
an ambulance to help her subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching